door on Staten Island New York for about
50 minutes all right good evening
everyone thanks for coming out to Barnes
& Noble tonight we are here to welcome
Terry Galway author of so others might
live history of the New York Fire
Department from 1700 to the present mr.
Galway will be here to discuss his book
and answer any questions you guys might
have and I just want to let you guys
know if you do have questions just wait
for the gentleman from c-span Pete and
showing to come around with the
microphone so we can hear your questions
very clearly so that's it please welcome
Terry go away well thank you it's nice
to be on Staten Island it's nice to see
so many friends and so many relatives
and it's also nice to see a fellow who I
remember from 35 years ago I remember
distinctly that pitch on the outside
corner and 10 year-old Arnie Matson
struck me out I was 12 years old and an
all-star he was 10 years old in a punk
and now he's running for Congress from
Staten Island so nice to see Arnie and
of course Arnie is a retired firefighter
something he has in common with a few
people here tonight and needless to say
I don't have to tell most of you this
but Staten Island is the perfect place
in a terrible way and in a great way to
start this book tour which I'm embarking
on tonight which will take me to six or
seven cities around the country Staten
Island I described in the book as the
Ground Zero of grief because on
September 11th Staten Island lost so
many people including 70 firefighters
more than 70 firefighters and many
civilians so much so that in one parish
I talk about the book st. Clair's my
father's old parish they were 30
funerals and memorial services 11 of
them
firefighters and the rest for civilians
Staten Island knew the cost of September
11th and one of the things that of
course is so attractive to Staten Island
even though there are parts of Staten
Island today that I don't necessarily
recognize from 35 years ago but one of
the things that I still find amazing is
that it is a place where firefighters
and police officers live side by side
with men and women who work at places
like canif it's Gerald Sandler O'Neal
it's a it's a wonderful community and I
think observing it from afar because I
live in New Jersey now observing it
through the work of the Staten Island
Advance after September 11th reading
stories of those firefighters you know
broke my heart and broke the hearts I
think of everybody one of the stories in
particular that touched me that I read
about in the advance that was written by
my old friend Jay Price was the story of
lieutenant Chuck marjatta meant some of
you may know Chuck I we cross paths in
high school I think we probably played
ball together a few times many years ago
and Jay price and his story about Chuck
mentioned that he was on his way home
from a night tour on September 11th
coming home about nine o'clock on the
Staten Island Expressway and he heard
about the attacks over the radio he gets
off the expressway and drives to the
nearest fire house which was the
quarters for rescue five gets on the rig
calls his mother while he's going over
the bridge and that's the last anybody
heard from him and one of the remarkable
things about that story I thought was
that spirit that led Chuck marjatta to
get off a highway and jump on a rig any
fire fire from 1940 from 1840 or from
1740 would have recognized that courage
and that instinct to go where you're
needed even though you don't have to be
there and Chuck margiana didn't have to
be there but he went there and as I say
one of the things that I was able to
see in in researching the history of the
fire department is that there was this
throughout the department's years and
even before the department was formed
firefighters went with they're needed
they don't think about the cost they
don't think about the potential they go
because they're needed so others might
live and what makes my book I think a
little bit different than many of the
September 11th books you're going to see
or have seen and what makes this book a
little bit different than maybe the
other fire fine firefighting books that
are out there now is that rather than
focus on one day September 11th in the
aftermath I took the story of the fire
department from it's very inception now
technically the Fire Department of New
York started in 1865 that was when New
York got its first professional fire
department but I looked at a broader
topic which is fire service that is you
know putting out fires and it's one of
those basic things when you think about
it you know so I took it all the way
back to Peter Stuyvesant snoo Amsterdam
where I discovered a few things that
would sound familiar I think even to
firefighters and New Yorkers today for
example Peter Stuyvesant one of the
first links Peter Stuyvesant did when he
took over in New Amsterdam because New
Hampshire's name was constantly burning
down you know they put up buildings that
burned down but another building it
burned down
I remind me the castle and Monty Python
in the holy grail they built it for them
same thing a New Amsterdam they don't
have any water and they didn't have any
building codes and so what you see a new
Amsterdam is the first sort of attempt
by a government to come in and tell
somebody what they can do and what they
can't do with their personal property
which was revolutionary in the 1600s you
had Stuyvesant come in at one point he
hires a couple of people and their job
is to go into everybody's house and
inspect their chimneys and inspect other
aspects of their structure and if they
were not up to the code they were fined
and if they didn't allow those
inspectors in they were fine so I sort
of described them as the sort of early
equivalent of meter readers that was
their job
come in and eventually Stuyvesant
realized that it is not necessarily a
good thing to build houses right on top
of each o'the at sounds like Staten
Island today I'm sorry but he thought it
was maybe not a good idea to build house
after house after house and have straw
roofs and expect these houses to
continue to function so he said about
doing something called zoning
regulations which obviously he's well
ahead of his time there so I thought
that that would be a good place to talk
about the fact that you know in urban
America you know as people began
settling in cities one of the first
things they had to do was figure out how
to put out fires and it was there in the
very beginning that you saw the first
firefighters in New York and things were
a little bit different back then
needless to say the way they put out
fires was they ran to the East River
loaded up the buckets ran with the
buckets and put out the fires that way
eventually they decided that this was
not necessarily the most effective way
to put out a fire but what to do in
seventeen in 1731 New York gets its
first fire engines and many historians
say that's where fire the fire service
in New York really started because once
you get fire engines over here all of a
sudden your average civilian who was
expected to volunteer it was yeah if
there was a fire in New Amsterdam or in
British New York before 1730 and you
were an able-bodied male you were
expected to man the bucket brigades well
once you get a fire engine and what they
basically had to do was fill it with
water pump it and then point it it's a
little bit more sophisticated they
decide the time has come for a volunteer
fire department so in around 1731 1732
you get New York's first fire department
and they are you know in many ways the
ancestors of the firefighters of today
and that volunteer force stayed that way
again until s 1865 and but in the in the
first in the first few years of American
independence New York reverted back to
form in 1776 1778 and throughout the
1820s New York is burning down again and
all of a sudden people are saying you
know we just can't have this these
volunteers are very good
you know we can't keep having the city
burn down and the sort of the
culmination of that period occurs at
1835 this was something I didn't know
much about I had been tinkering with the
idea of doing a history of the fire
department before September 11th it
being the son of a firefighter and
son-in-law and godson and cousin and
nephew and everything else I couldn't
help but know a little bit about the
fire department history but what I
didn't know was that in 1835 New York
suffered a catastrophe that is eerily
similar to September 11th except for the
fact that September 11th costs the lives
of 3,000 people and the what is called
the Great Fire of 1835 actually ended in
only two deaths but the destruction was
simply amazing 650 buildings burned down
and about 52 acres of downtown Manhattan
were wiped out in fact after that fire
was over it occurred in December of 1835
most people in America decided that New
York was finished that the future
financial capital of America would be to
be Boston or Philadelphia New York was
gone and what was really striking after
that fire and I saw the records up at
the New York Historical Society I don't
know when the last time anybody looked
at them was but what was really striking
and heartening and again reminding you
of September 11th is that after this
utter catastrophe after basically
downtown New York ceased to exist in
1835 the citizens of Boston Philadelphia
Albany Buffalo Montreal throughout the
Northeast United States and Canada came
together and asked the federal
government well the citizens of Montreal
didn't they had no business they've just
they donated money but the citizens of
the United States came together and
asked Washington to do the unprecedented
which was to which would be to step in
and help New York in its hour of need
and a Boston congressman got up on the
floor of the house and said New York's
disaster is the nation's disaster New
York's catastrophe is a national
catastrophe and so for the first time in
American history in 1835 you have the
federal government taking the step
assisting a community after a disaster
and obviously that has continued that
policy has continued but it had never
happened until that time one of the
anthem aftermath of the 1835 fire which
affected the fire department a great
deal was that the politicians decided
that the fire department was not very
good and so among the things they did
was they started insulting the fire
chief now those of you who are
firefighters in the audience know it is
never a good thing for politicians to
insult a fire chief and sure enough on
January 1st 1836 there was a fire and an
alderman sort of a City Councilman and
aldermen went to the fire as he was
required to do and he was carrying his
staff these days if a politician's
carrying his staff at some politician
because the staffs about but this was a
real staff so the firemen recognized
poor alderman Purdy and they get off the
fire truck and they said you know where
do you think you're going and the poor
old ermine says well you know I'm an
alderman well that was the point so they
beat him up and one of the assailants
was a guy named light body
now John light body everything I've read
about John light body suggests to me
that he was not particularly well named
but he he apparently got off pretty easy
and this led to a great tension between
politicians and the fire department
fatwood as Mayor Bloomberg would
probably tell you continues to exist to
this day so at one point to get back at
the fire department in the mid in Mid
1836 the City Council or Common Council
it was called at the time the Common
Council decides they're gonna fire the
fire chief whose name was James go 'ok
so the word got down no you talk about
bad timing I mean there might be a time
to fire a fire chief but is generally
accepted I think that you don't fire a
fire chief while there's a fire in
progress the Common Council of the city
of New York decided to fire the fire
chief while he was on duty with his men
and they were all men back then of
course
and when word got down to the
firefighters they said oh okay well
we're leaving too and left the scene of
a fire so many of there are some people
in this audience who participated in the
UFA Fire Department strike in 1973 and
many people said it was no history
because the first time the fire
department had walked off the job in a
labor dispute
uh-uh 1836 they walked away from that
fire and eventually were persuaded to
come back to the fire by the chief
himself who said you know maybe there's
a time and a place for this but not now
so in any case chief gelec was fired and
with the fire department decided to do
to get back to the politicians was they
ran him for an obscure office called the
city register had no power but the fire
department was determined to make a
point that it will brook no interference
from politicians politicians can run the
city we will run the fire department we
will tell we will decide how to put out
fires thank you very much
so they run this guy garlic for city
register and the view to see the
editorials in the newspaper saying well
who do these firefighters think they
think a firefighter is going of course
they said fireman back then you think a
fireman is going to win an election
based on what well cast spot he won and
then the next election the firefighters
did it again they picked one of their
own random for office for state assembly
and won so there was a precedent
Barney Matson for firefighters winning
elections in New York so what what that
led to was sort of being what be but it
led to was politicians standing up and
saying you know what these firefighters
mean business and maybe there's
something we should we should do some
outreach here community outreach so
beginning of the sort of the 1840s after
this incident
New York's clubhouses political club
houses Tammany Hall and other club
houses begin to sort of merge with fire
houses so you get this very interesting
thing where the the best way to get a
fire department job and they were all
volunteers back then but so many people
wanted to volunteer that they're often
waiting lists the best way to become a
volunteer firefighter was to sort of get
affiliated with either your local
political Clubhouse
or your local gang sometimes they were
interchangeable and the one of the most
famous firefighters in the 19th century
did just that
his name was William tweed you might
know him as boss tweed he gained fame
and some bit of fortune by becoming a
volunteer firefighter and he was so
popular he was elected to become the
foreman of Engine six which was called
the big six the foreman would be roughly
the equivalent of a captain and that was
how he got his political career started
now in the meantime in a very
interesting things going on in New York
where volunteer fire companies are sort
of jockeying with each other for the
privilege of putting out a fire because
back then you didn't have battalions
didn't have this yeah the first point at
the fire put it out and of course it was
considered to be a great honor to put
out a fire and it was created considered
a dishonor to not put out the fire you
were there first you get the hose
everybody else is on the relay so as a
result firefighters started to express
their opinions to one another in a way
that was occasionally violent in fact
I'm just going to read a little bit of
the book in in around 8:00 in the late
1840s there was one of the great battles
ever fought by the fire department and
nothing to do with fire but everything
to do with fighting and a guy who a
historian who rode in the 19th century
who knew some of the people involved
described that this fight this way he
said the shock of battle rolled down the
line and quicker than it takes to write
these words 1,000 sturdy stalwart
fellows were fiercely grappling one
another in hand-to-hand fight the din
was frightful the fighters were so thick
there was scarcely room for one to fall
those who are lucky enough to fight to
find Mother Earth were nearly trampled
to death by the feet of friend and foe
before they could escape those were from
ng company 15 and from engine company 40
so I needless to say there was some
sentiment in the city that maybe it was
not a good idea for fire fighters to be
fighting each other while they are
supposed to be fighting fires so a new
chief was brought in a guy by the name
of Alfred Carson and you knew there was
going to be trouble
between the politicians and the fire
department and chief Carson when the
newspapers reported reported that chief
Carson's favorite beverage was
sarsaparilla that was a tip-off that
maybe this guy was serious about
reforming fire department and the
politicians because what's also going on
at this time is the gangs are beginning
to attack fire fighters
just for the fun of it and for those of
you who fought fires in the Bronx and in
Brooklyn and in well mostly Brooklyn and
Bronx in parts of Manhattan will
recognize what that because many in many
cases that was similar in the 1960s when
firefighters came under attack and
people were shocked and rightfully so
well the same thing was going on in the
1850s and Carson the chief was
determined to protect his firefighters
from the gangs protect his firefighters
from the politicians but also to protect
his firefighters from one another from
the you know the firefighters like bill
tweed so one day in 1850 bill tweed the
future boss gets into an unbelievable
brawl with Engine six his men in engine
six and another fire company and Carson
says well this is just unacceptable so
the Board of Aldermen oh did I mention
that bill tweed had run for political
office by this time the Board of
Aldermen decide that Bill tweed is to be
suspended as a firefighter forever
well the neck says so with some
conversations took place and the next
day the Board of Aldermen met in secret
session where resolution at we don't
know what happened because it was in
secret session but the gist I think was
that the Board of Aldermen decided that
it pursuant to the case of William tweed
the term and word forever is to be
defined as no more than 90 days so built
we got off and Carson chief Carson went
bananas and he went before the City
Council and he called them basically a
bunch of rogues and dared them to fire
him and went on and on and carried on
forever and as a result cheap costumes
fired because after all you don't go
before the Board of Aldermen and say
that they're a bunch of rogues and
thieves and expect to get away with it
so these rather colorful part of New
York's firefighting history of course in
that time of course there were many
fires and the department was beginning
to resemble the kind of urban fire
department we have today except for the
fact that there were so many of them
there was at by the 1860s there are
about 5,000 firefighters the City
Council is just if you want to be a
firefighter sure you want to find your
own company fine that's that's fine so
eventually in 1865 the the powers that
be in New York mainly the insurance
industry and you can understand why the
building industry and to a lesser extent
the politicians mostly the the
capitalists of the time said you know
what we really we need a professional
fire service there's just no question
about that
and so after much wrangling in 1865
right before the end of the Civil War
the fire department of New York is
formed and that is the beginning of sort
of the modern history of the fire
department and from 5,000 volunteers it
went down to 1,000 paid firefighters
this was now going to be their job now
the interesting thing that happens over
the next few decades is that
firefighters because of what had
happened in the 1840s and 1850s which
sounds like a lot of fun now but I mean
if your building was burning down and
they were fighting it doesn't sound so
much fun but uh firefighters had sort of
come into a bit of disrepute and yeah it
was obviously not the real firefighters
would being each other up it was the
Bilt weeds you know of the real
politicians of the time so it all eyes
were really on these professional
firefighters now in 1865 to sort of show
what a real firefighter could do and
it's at that time you see the emergence
of people like a fellow who I discovered
I knew nothing about John Bresnan who
becomes a battalion chief and in
battalion six and he and Hugh Bonner who
not only becomes a battalion chief he
eventually becomes the chief of
department and then Commissioner uh and
these two are Irish immigrants who fled
Ireland in the 1840s who grew up in the
Five Points now many of you know the
five
neighborhood in Manhattan in the 1850s
was the worst neighborhood by far and
New York public opinion in the 1860s was
not particularly friendly to the Irish
not particularly friendly to immigrants
not particularly friendly to Catholics
and there was a suggestion that a
department which is dominated by this
group would invariably fall back on bad
habits and what I find amazing and
interesting and very moving about John
Breslin who was born poor and Hugh
Bonner also born poor living in the five
points is that these two men and others
but these two men turned the fire
department turned fire service into fire
science they are the ones who start the
school of instruction for the first time
New York firefighters in the 1880s are
now getting trained they're the ones who
insisted on civil service testing that
so they're asking the fire department to
maintain the highest professional
standards they can and again what's
amazing about that is nobody in the
1860s would have ever expected that from
a couple of Irish Catholics from the
five points they would have expected
just the opposite and Breslin in
particular is an interesting character
first of all because I was able to track
down his great great grandson who was a
lieutenant and who retired just before
September 11th there were four
generations of the present family
connected to the fire department but he
also was a reformer and he and Bonner
were both reformers in the sense that
they wanted to bring social change to
the neighborhoods that they had left
behind so when you begin to see the
1890s is these two great Chiefs going to
the Protestant establishment of New York
and saying we've got to do something
about people living in the tenements and
this is at a time where Jacob Riis has
written how the other half lives how New
Yorkers are beginning to realize that
there's this immigrant population on the
Lower East Side and other places that
are living in deplorable conditions and
it's time to do something about it
so you get these two men who were from
those deplorable conditions who say yes
and that's not the half of it you should
see the fire hazards you should see the
fire escapes that for the most part
don't exist but when they do exist
they're filled with junk you should see
the landlord's who aren't adhering to
the most rudimentary building codes and
so they work with these elite New
Yorkers who were part of the housing
reform commission of the 1890s and they
basically make life better and safer for
poor New Yorkers and this is sort of
fire prevention at its very beginnings
at what points either Bonner or or
president I remember each one which one
basically said I'd rather prevent a fire
than then put one out of course that was
the exact opposite of what the
volunteers in the 1840s they wanted
prevent fires they wanted to fight them
because that's what they did but but in
the 1890s you begin to see much more of
an emphasis on prevention through these
two characters and John Breslin
unfortunately comes to a very very sad
and he he was a widower with three
children and he died in a fire in 1894
when a water tank collapsed through a
building leaving his children orphans of
course one of those one of his sons
winds up becoming the chief dispatcher
from the Bronx so he also had the title
of chief he retired in the 1950s his son
became a firefighter and his son bill
Breslin of Ladder 15 I guess in downtown
he he was the fella I talked to who
watched the Twin Towers fall a few
months after he had retired and the the
great transition that took place in the
fire department after these guys kind of
lead the scene is of course the you know
the modern fire department New York
comes into existence in 1898 with the
consolidation of the five boroughs into
one one city of New York because until
then the New York Fire Department
consisted of Manhattan and parts of the
Bronx so all of a sudden you've got now
the fire department is responsible for
300 square miles and just give you an
idea of what some of the statistics were
like the fire department
in 1898 consisted of 63 engine companies
and 22 latter companies and twelve
hundred firefighters once the five
boroughs come into existence all of a
sudden its 121 engine companies 46
ladder companies and about 3,000
firefighters that includes the
volunteers who are on Staten Island so
that's the sort of beginning of the fire
department of New York as we know it and
the first sort of one of the first great
tests of the fire department in the 20th
century is really one of the most famous
fires to this day in New York and in the
United States and that would be the
Triangle Shirtwaist fire and that fire
set off a series of reforms that led to
really you would argue I know Uncle Mike
Feuer would disagree with this but sort
of the spectacular rise of the New Deal
in Franklin Roosevelt but but just to
remind you of what the Triangle
Shirtwaist Fire was all about they're in
a factory on the ninth floor of the
building that still stands off
Washington Square Park was factory
textile factory employed mostly teenaged
girls Jewish immigrants who worked you
know day in and day out under deplorable
conditions and at that time there was
another great chief of the New York Fire
Department by the name of Edward Croker
and croakie was the nephew of Richard
croaker who was sort of the boss tweet
of his day but sort of Edward Croker was
the good croaker a spectacular fireman
fantastic fireman but everybody thought
he got his job through his nephew turned
out not at all he was he had won medals
he had won all sorts of honors and he
becomes one of the great Chiefs of the
fire department and in 1911 at the
Triangle Shirtwaist Fire
not long after croaker had gone to the
factory owners and had gone to Wall
Street and says and said to them in so
many words something has to be done
about the conditions that these people
are working in not to say he didn't
mention Triangle Shirtwaist he mentioned
factories in general you have to have
fire escapes you have to have clear
paths the fire escapes you have to have
a minimal minimal adherence to a fire
code and he and what was said about him
oh he's just trying to sell sprinklers
you know he's Richard Crocker's nephew
so he was defamed for this and at the
Triangle Shirtwaist Fire Edward Croker
is on the sidewalk watching bodies
plummet from the 9th and 10th floors of
the Triangle Shirtwaist Fire and he
delivers one of the most impassioned
speeches I think I've ever heard to the
reporters who were there and he says and
this is again as his tragedy is
unfolding nine stories above he said he
said look around everywhere Jess
gesturing to the smoking buildings
nowhere will you find fire escapes they
they say they don't look sightly I have
tried to force their installation and
only last Friday a Manufacturers
Association met in Wall Street to oppose
my plan the large loss of life is due to
this neglect this is while it's
happening Kroger is pointing fingers and
I think personally pointing them in the
right direction because with Croker you
have the continuation of something that
continues today that of the crusading
fire chief who is telling the New York
building industry who's telling the
people who put up skyscrapers you have
to think about fire they may look pretty
but you have to think about fire and
they didn't listen back then and if you
listen to another great crusading chief
who's who still he's retired now chief
any done a legend in the New York Fire
Department they're expert in building
collapses he is campaigning to get
better construction downtown when New
York when downtown New York is rebuilt
Vinnie Don is in the great tradition of
fire chief's from President to Bonner to
O'Hagan and now Tiffany Dunn and he's
doing this whole public service so there
again I picked up a theme that I thought
resonated with what was going on today
where you have a great disaster and and
fire chief saying look you know when we
do this again let's do it right let's
spend a little money let's put in some
sprinklers
let's get better construction methods
let's not care so much about what it
looks like let's care about whether it's
safe
now I I want to take some questions in a
couple of minutes but I do want to talk
a little bit about the what a chapter I
call the war years and the reason I want
to talk a little bit about that is
because some people in this room fought
in the war years and we're talking about
the that time in the fire department
from 1966 to 1978 it was a time of total
disintegration socially throughout the
country and the fire department of New
York was on the frontlines of that
battle and most firefighters you talked
to who were on the job particularly
those who were in what we understand
I'll refer to was the city those who
fought in there referred to it as the
war years because to give you an idea of
what was going on in the fire department
of New York and in New York in the 1960s
in 1960 the number of false alarms in
New York was 13,000 326 in 1967 that
number was 48,000 106 and by 1978 number
false alarms in the city of New York two
hundred eighty five thousand two hundred
ninety the number of fires in 1960 60
thousand nine hundred forty one 1977 129
thousand six hundred nineteen 1976 150
3263 all that while the fire department
of New York was shrinking from 14,000 to
11,000 during the height of the fiscal
crisis firefighters were getting laid
off they went on strike for five and a
half hours in 1973 and their workload as
you can see increased immeasurably and
one of the amazing things I find is I
talk to veterans of those days people
who were in Bushwick in 1977 during the
blackout when Bushwick burned and
continued to burn for the next five
years I talked with people who fought
fires in the South Bronx and they all
said you know there's nowhere else I
would have rather been we went to work
knowing we were going to fight a fire
maybe two maybe even three if we were
lucky that was that was the enthusiasm
they brought to the job and I personally
just find that remarkable but of all the
things that
or horrific I think the spread of false
alarms in the 70s signified to me as
clearly a sad commentary on New York and
I talked to a guy who later was at the
command post in the North Tower of the
World Trade Center on September 11th a
guy a chief by the name of Pete Hayden
and he said to me that when he was in
rescue 2 in Brooklyn he could trace the
pattern of false alarms he said it would
be 3 o'clock in the afternoon and you
get an alarm from the pull box outside
the local school then you'd get one
three blocks down the street then
another one a few blocks away then you
get another one and you realize he or
she had turned east or west it was going
down the block they could trace one
person one kid going from the school
home by the alarm boxes they poked and
quite frankly in that context it really
was no wonder that the ufa in 1973 had
said to the city look this is enough you
know we you've got to do something for
us and that it was those that sort of
contentious time that led to the five
and a half hour strike in 1972 things
improved immeasurably for the fire
department
once Ed Koch became mayor and the city
started to become a little bit fat
fiscally and the note I'd like to end on
is actually not about September 11th
because I think we've heard enough about
September 11th of today certainly we'll
never know
learn enough about it but a couple of
months ago when I was writing this book
I talked with two veteran firefighters
one Reggie Julius 78 years old and very
Julius his brother 75 years old he was a
captain Reggie was a battalion chief
from 12th tine they're both
african-american firefighters who came
on the job Reggie in 1949 Vinny in 1951
and they told me stories that you know
it was tough to be an african-american
firefighter in the late 40s and early
50s but when I had lunch with them in
May the day ray down he was buried I
think was May they they didn't want to
talk about that they just wanted to talk
about the job they wanted to talk about
how much fun it was
to be a firefighter at what point Vinny
Julian said to me any sort of describes
I think pretty well about something
about firefighting he said it's about
ordinary people who have found a calling
over and above what the average person
does you go into a burning building down
the hallway you see what we call the red
demon and that red demons fingers are
reaching out for you and they're saying
come on come on I've got something for
you come on and you put down your head
and you keep moving I wish I could make
up that kind of dialogue but that's what
vinnie julie has told me and later on a
few minutes later this fantastic
storyteller and his brother we were
outside looking at the firehouse near my
house in South Orange New Jersey and
sort of comparing notes looking at the
rig and of course nothing as good as the
fire department you are Kinison looking
at the small fire house and small fire
company and instead of being very
patronizing very nice but at one point
Vinny Julius we hit with it getting in
the car to go home and Reggie Julius
opens up his trunk and inside of his
trunk he's got his own old turnout coat
and his hat is his helmet from 12th to
tyne and his boots I said what are they
for I mean chief you know he's not off
the job 15 years he was at Ground Zero
at 78 years old working 12-hour shifts
and of course that was amazing and he
closed the trunk and then I talked to
his brother Vinny Julius who was smoking
cigarette see I go for realism here now
and he he put out the cigarette and he
said you know I'm 75 years old he said
I've had a good life I've had a great
career I could die tomorrow but if I die
tomorrow I'm coming back as a
firefighter for the city of New York
thank you very much
questions ms Monaghan a Holt wait wait
uh hi Terry
um your dad was a firefighter how much
um input did you get from him and your
Godfather in writing this book that Jim
well there are two ways of answering the
question one the truth one anomaly well
you know I mean obviously I've been
hearing stories about the fire
department you know since since I was a
kid and that was one of the reasons why
I had thought about doing this history
before 9/11 a couple about a year ago or
so a guy by name's Tom Repetto wrote a
history of the police department it was
at that time I was thinking well gee you
know I know a little bit about the fire
department maybe you know I should start
putting together some material here and
maybe you know someday you know I'll get
a book contract write in history the
fire department but I think that one of
the things that I thought was important
bulla yeah I was called I was on the
phone with my father particularly near
deadline I would say I looked at tell me
again the standpipe now telly explain to
me again what the standpipe work how
that works and look you know how do you
how do you do that hydrant thing I mean
you know III didn't know and I certainly
consulted my father on the you know and
and my Uncle Frank
my godfather I I talked to them about
the strike you know because this is
living history and they lived through it
so of course I talked to them but by the
same token you know I I did want to
write a history even though I'm a
firefighters son and son-in-law and
godson and cousin and nephew I did want
to write a history that was objective
that was a work of scholarship and that
was that that told it as I saw it and
while this book is clearly a tribute to
the courage and bravery and sacrifice
and selflessness of not just the New
York Fire Department but a firefighters
everywhere this book is dedicated to my
parents my in-laws my godfather and to
firefighting families and I think that
the attributes that you saw on September
11th were not unique in many ways to the
Fire Department of New York they're
unique to firefighters emergency
personnel everywhere they are they are
heroes not you know athletes not
Hollywood celebrities these people do
the work so in that respect I was you
know I've been consulting my father and
Godfather every day of my life and boy
they're probably pretty tired of it any
other questions I certainly could tell
some other stories yes it's a full-time
writer anyway did you have a hard time
focusing on the book and your full-time
job how was that process I excuse me I
happen to work for a very generous
employer called the New York Observer
Arthur Carter is my publisher Peter
Caplan is my editor and they knew how
important this book was to me so they
very generously said look you take
whatever time you need to write this
book you know check back with us every
now and again you know let us know that
you're aware that it's 2002 we're not in
fact 1840 and let us know that you know
that the mayor is Bloomberg and that the
county leader is not boss tweed but so
they were very very understanding this
is my fifth book I've written at The
Observer and every time I'm amazed at
the generosity of my employers so that's
the answer and I also by the way have a
very patient wife and two children who
know not to bother me when I'm sort of
muttering in front of the laptop that's
very important to him actually they do
bother me on occasion but yeah that's
right mr. Matz to have a question
well one thing about education this book
will educate people most of the books on
a fire department we've read in the last
year talk about two weeks two months of
a certain situation in the city this
goes back to the history of the fire
department and when I first got on a
fire department in 1981 it was a history
that I didn't know much about and there
were some old books in the firehouse and
you'd be some old stories and what they
call that WNY F magazine which was with
New York City firefighters and that was
the magazine where you'd read those
articles about president I writing
croaker and they would always talk about
these Chiefs but you'd only see these
magazines in the firehouse you know it's
sort of like today where normally the
only time you would see somebody wear an
FDNY hat it would be a fireman the only
time you'd see somebody wearing an FDNY
t-shirt would be a fireman and you kind
of knew if you'd see somebody at a
little league game or if you saw him at
a touch tackle football game or even at
a PTA meeting late at night you knew
that was that guy was a fine man because
he wore that t-shirt by today's
standards I was up to Ground Zero two
weeks ago and it just shows the
curiosity of the people and they want to
be part of like when the Yankees finally
got back into the World Series
everybody's wearing a Yankee hat again
but Terry I want to tell you that uh
this is a book that should have been
around thirty years ago and I'm glad
you've taken the time to write it
because a lot of the books written in
the last year were put together in a
week
and I'm sure that you really put the
time in and I didn't know Terry starting
back in Our Lady Help a Christian school
and Tottenville going back to the 60s
when we were in school when his father
was fighting fires my father was a
policeman for 25 years and we were sons
of civil servants and a civil servant
there's a lot of people that go to
Manhattan every day and and don't really
know what that means but they got a good
taste of it and I got a never ending
story last September 11th because the
word servant is what it's all about
and I wish you luck with the book and
tell the people what's next on the
agenda cuz I'm looking forward to
getting your next book - well thanks
Arnie well as a matter of fact I am
working on another book III had been
working on it I had been working on it
with 9/11 happened I'm working on a
biography of a Revolutionary War general
named Nathaniel Greene who sort of at
George Washington's side everywhere but
you know as is true of most sidekicks
you know you remember Costello
you remember Abbott you know for the
most part you know he's been ignored you
know and I found it amazing that this
one general could be at so many battles
and and sort of not have his due
so while I was formulating the idea
writing history the fire department I
actually was working on General Greene
and then once 9/11 happened I thought
General Greene could wait a little while
and and I would get to this more
pressing issue but hopefully that book
will be out in about a year and a half
and you know that'll be on to another
one
yes fire and then shortly thereafter you
talked about the World Trade Center for
catastrophe do you see any relationship
between the two and in the codes and and
the the causes of the the catastrophic
damage and injury well sure that's a
very good question I mean in the case of
Triangle Shirtwaist firemen you had
criminal neglect that certainly wouldn't
be true in the World Trade Center I mean
obviously that was that was an act of
war that was not gross negligence as the
Triangle Shirtwaist Fire was however you
know if you would talk to some people
who are a lot smarter than I am about
building codes like Vinnie done she's
been he done you know he'll tell you
that the lightweight construction that
went into the World Trade Center well
and that's designed to get more floor
space you know you build it that way you
get more floor space you can make more
money right
Vinnie Dunn's told me that a
firefighters idea of a skyscraper is the
Empire State Building cement solid
construction you
their idea of a horror is the World
Trade Center and so I guess the
correlation would be once again the fire
department is going to be going to
builders and architects and people like
that and and the real-estate industry
and the insurance industry and they're
going to say let's not let this happen
again let's do something let's be
proactive let's spend a little money to
do what's right rather than to do what's
cheapest and what's most cost-effective
and what you can make the most money so
I think there is a correlation in that
sense in the sense that the department
has always been on the side of greater
safety and and stricter building codes
anybody
yep
Brian Hawk you don't have a question
come on
forgive me if I'm duplicating a
something that might have been touched
on already but in the Reese my
grandfather was a fireman and an uncle
is what my grandfather worked in
downtown Brooklyn at the J Street
firehouse they fought fires on piers
they fought fires with equipment that
was some so primitive compared to what
they have today when you talked to the
men who've been in the business of
determining what's the best equipment
how do we fight the fires of the future
is there any sense that this will be a
safe job a generation from now is it
possible that the wives of firemen 20
years from now won't have to worry that
there may have walk-in home the next day
well unfortunately you know the answer
to that is no a bill Finn the first
deputy commissioner who is killed on
September 11th at the age of 71 years
old he gave an interview which was being
played at the New York Historical
Society the last time I was there a few
months ago it was on a loop and he said
you know very eloquently this was taped
a couple of months before September 11th
and he said you know and his voice sort
of echoed in my mind as I was writing
this book and trying to answer that very
question and he said you know there have
been seven hundred and something
firefighters killed in line of duty that
was before September 11th and he said no
matter what we do no matter how much we
invest in technology no matter how much
we think buildings are fireproof there's
going to be a 700 that that number is
going to go higher it's the nature of
the job so but hopefully there will be
lessons learned you know not just from
the from what happened at the World
Trade Center which of course was a was
it or not let's hope is an anomaly but
you know from fires that happened - you
know one of the things that firefighters
actually sometimes complain about is
that the there are no big fires anymore
you know they actually complain about
that which I find amazing but people
still get people to get killed and men
women are putting their lives in danger
all the time but nothing is going to
take the risk out of firefighting which
you notice says a lot about the people
who choose that as their profession I
like to really something like because if
you're shooting in there you're gonna
get okay can we get Terry goal ways
father father-in-law Godfather and
uncles were all New York firefighters so
others might live is published by basic
books online at basic books calm next
week on history on book TV pauline mayor
and other historians discuss their book
inventing america